[Music]
I think we have to start with this
because it's it's here and it's here
right now I'm saying it's Friday it's
here
coward Bieber quavo chance - rapper it's
a no-brainer
at this point do you just call them up
do you text them how do you get him look
how do you get them involved
well I facetimed Bieber and I was like
yo I don't even give him a chance to say
hi he picked up the FaceTime that's your
beaver check this I know I ain't
supposed to be calling you right now
and say let's make another record
together cuz we made one last he's like
man send it send it send it right now so
I texted to him and he hit me back
immediately and said man this is amazing
let's get it done and work with a big
icon like that but not just that he's my
friend I'm saying if somebodyís getting
to know better and better every day and
he's just a good person you know I mean
you meet people in this world but then
you meet this some great good genuine
he's just so genuine and nice and
amazing beautiful soul and he's just
incredible man Justin Bieber thank you
so much for believing in me because you
know you don't really do features he
doesn't with you that's big that's a
no-brainer what is it like seeing him so
happy and in love right now I'm in love
too so I know the feeling and I'm so
happy for him because I know what love
does you know it makes you not only feel
good it makes you just great love is
just a beautiful thing for him to find
somebody he loves and wants to marry
that's incredible that's beautiful god
bless you I can't wait for the wedding
I'm sure it's gonna be incredible
are we gonna see you guys perform this
song at the wedding I mean that would be
a no-brainer I'm saying so your Bieber
let's make it happen let's perform
no-brainer at your wedding with you
performing in it you're saying I'd be
crazy right the epic that'd be a
no-brainer another one dj khaled filling
on bieber and their new collab
no-brainer which also features quavo and
chance the rapper khaled is also
finishing out season two of the four
let's talk about the finale really fast
what are you looking for in tonight's
performances looking for something I've
never seen ever in my life
made me feel a certain way I've never
felt or heard in my life
let's break that new star that the world
been waiting for that the fans haven't
heard I'm saying when you come out on
that stage and you want primetime TV
there's really no excuses for you not to
be great so I didn't get that
opportunity coming up you say I'm not
saying they're not working hard I'm
saying it was just a different time you
know I have et I have Instagram I have
before so I to go see city black for
black and get people talking okay calico
they get in the whole world on the
number one show in the world the biggest
TV show which is amazing but also a
testament to you because you're also
about to hit the road with Beyonce and
jay-z does it get bigger than that I
just dropped a new record no brain I'm
going on tour with jay-z and Beyonce man
we the best man we feeling great right
now I mean god is great I'm grateful I'm
on the biggest show on TV he's
definitely coming out of some shows he's
definitely sock aside everywhere I go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]